everybody knows Hollywood loves remaking
classic movies but that's not always a
bad thing sure there are plenty of
boring copycats out there but for every
unimaginative reimagining there's an
amazing remake that feels nothing like
the original the thing john carpenter's
1982 film the thing is a remake of the
1951 the thing from another world but as
far as remakes go the two movies are
different creatures sure both versions
are set in snowy wastelands where an
alien terrorizes humans and murders sled
dogs in both movies the thing hates fire
and is defeated by a pilot but that's
where the similarities end in the 51
movie the monster is a gigantic humanoid
vegetable the humans work together to
defeat it which is the opposite of what
happens in the remake instead of
fighting an intellectual carrot the
characters in the 82 film face a slimy
shape-shifter that absorbs and
impersonates his victims the heroes in
the thing are constantly suspicious of
each other and never sure who's human
most importantly the 51 film ends with
the alien defeated but the 82 film has
one of the most ambiguous endings ever
as bleak and cold as outpost 31
wait here for a little while see what
happens
hi Ryder Shane is one of the all-time
great westerns this 1953 film follows a
mysterious gunfighter played by Alan
Ladd who defends homesteaders from an
evil cattle baron in 1985 Clint Eastwood
unofficially remade the movie as Pale
Rider
as the enigmatic preacher eastward rides
into a downtrodden mining camp and
defends the locals from a powerful Gold
tycoon in both movies a cold-blooded
gunslinger standing on a porch shoots
down a well-meaning hothead and both
movies end with the hero riding into the
distance with an obsessed kid calling
out after him despite the similarities
there's one enormous otherworldly
difference
Shane is human and preacher is the ghost
of a dead gunfighter who only shows up
after a little girl asks God for a
miracle Little Shop of Horrors the 1986
film Little Shop of Horrors is a big
brassy musical about a nerdy Flores
played by Rick Moranis and a man-eating
plant with dreams of world dominance
directed by Frank Oz this over-the-top
monster flick features Steve Martin as a
sadistic dentist and a giant singing
Venus flytrap the film was inspired by
an off-broadway play but if you go
further back you can follow little shops
roots to the 1960 original while the
basic plot is the same for both movies
that the original wasn't a musical the
blood-hungry plant is far more talkative
in the remake but the biggest difference
is the ending in the remakes theatrical
ending the hero saves the world from the
giant plant but in the original the lead
is devoured and turned into the world's
most horrific flower he was such a good
boy
I didn't mean it 12 monkeys in 1995 12
monkeys a super virus has ravaged the
earth the survivors send a prisoner
played by Bruce Willis back in time to
find the disease's origin while it
certainly feels like an original movie
its basic premise
lifted from a 1962 French film called La
Jetee which shares a nearly identical
plot just like the prisoner in 12
monkeys the hero of Elijah Tay is
haunted by a childhood memory of a man
gunned down at an airport in both films
the hero discovers that thanks to the
curse of time travel the guy he saw shot
down as an airport was his future self
and now he's stuck in a never-ending
time loop what truly sets these movies
apart is that 12 monkeys is a
traditional movie while la jetée is
experimental art the black and white
French film is only 28 minutes long and
is told with still images and a narrator
Rise of the Planet of the Apes the
modern Planet of the Apes franchise
takes a whole lot of liberties from the
original eight pentalogy so you might
not realize that 2011 s Rise of the
Planet of the Apes is also a remake of
the fourth film in the original series
1972 s conquest of the Planet of the
Apes both movies follow an ape named
Caesar who leads a primates revolt
against humans but the Caesar of the
2011 remake played by Andy Serkis is far
more benevolent than the original Caesar
played by Roddy McDowall circuses
character is a Moses type who leads his
fellow Apes to freedom while McDowell's
Caesar is driven by righteous anger and
vengeance Rhys takes place in modern
times whereas the 1972 conquest takes
place in a totalitarian era where apes
are used for slave labor but perhaps the
most important distinction is that it
rised the apes use Spears and in
conquest they kill bad guys with machine
guns
the modern reboot would have to wait
another movie for that Pete's dragon if
you compare the 1977 Pete's dragon to
the 2016 remake you could sum up the
similarities in one sentence an orphan
boy named Pete befriends a magical
dragon named Elliot other than Matt
these two movies are totally different
beasts most notably the original Elliot
is covered in scales but the new one
looks like a fuzzy green dog and Pete's
backstory is different in the original
he's a runaway and in the remake
he's been stranded in the forest after a
car crash
both films feature a villain who wants
to capture the dragon although the
motives of the 77 villain are somewhat
more sinister we could make a million by
slicing him dicing him the biggest
difference between the two films is that
the original is musical while there's
not a single show tune in the remake
that's probably a good thing because
we're not sure if Robert Redford could
have pulled off the whole Mickey Rooney
song and dance routine the Magnificent 7
Antoine Fuqua 2016 remake of the
Magnificent Seven features a mustachioed
Denzel Washington and a cowboy Chris
Pratt fighting an army of gun-slinging
assassins
it might not compare to the 1960 version
which was itself a remake of Seven
Samurai but the modern update got some
much-needed upgrades the cast is much
more diverse and one of the most
important characters is female which
allows for some more dynamic
storytelling in the original Mexican
farmers fend off bandits but in the
remake a group of towns folk defend
their property from a psychopathic
robber baron Washington's character is
partly driven by revenge while your
Brenner's man in black is fighting for
the farmers solely because it's the
right thing to do both movies have their
pros and cons but at the end of the day
well it was
magnificent
[Music]